I meant what I said the whole idea is
just irresponsible so what it's more
grown-up to settle for a living and fear
behind some stupid wall your old
pointless life yes actually yes it is it
is indeed more grown-up to settle for
living in fear behind some stupid walls
for your whole pointless life in fact
it's such a good idea I'm about to prove
it to you
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory an
essential part of a balanced Titan
breakfast and that's got to be on the
list of top 10 worst ways to go but it's
horrific eaten alive deaths like that
that got me to include attack on Titan
as a part of my October weenie Theory
lineup weenie theories theory is about
Halloweeny things scary stuff and don't
have a crouton all you salad finger fans
part two is happening it just needed a
little bit more time to get dressed
salad fingers get dressed YouTube comedy
gold right there ladies and gentlemen
now for those of you who are unfamiliar
with attack on Titan it's all about a
society that builds a huge wall around
itself to keep out the unwanted I will
build the greatest wall that you've ever
seen
looks like Trump's got some kind of
petition maybe this whole show depicts
America's future
hashtag theory for another day anyway
instead of building walls to keep out
illegal immigrants tightens walls are
meant to keep out man-eating Giants you
see about a hundred years ago under
mysterious circumstances giants called
Titans suddenly appeared and started
eating every single Beauty human in
their sight like me devouring a handful
of crispy M&Ms so crunchy if the
remnants of humanity fled retreating
into a fortress protected by three huge
walls the outermost wall was named wall
Marya on the second wall rosa and the
innermost wall wall Sina the poor lived
between Marya and Rosa while the rich
live in the innermost wall wall Sina
much like these walls and onions and
ogres the series itself has many layers
where do the Titans actually come from
why do they eat humans and why do they
always look like they're taking the
worst yearbook photo ever
now I already know that a lot of these
mysteries have been answered in the
manga but in the anime none of yet to be
revealed and by the creator's own
admission much of the upcoming season
two will be a complete departure from
the source material so for this episode
I'll be focusing exclusively on the
anime to answer the single greatest
attack on titan mystery of them all with
man-eating Giants roaming the outside
world what's the best way to survive do
you go outside the walls facing certain
death and try to reclaim earth for
Humanity or do you just hunker down
inside the walls safe but trapped like
animals like the show says
was a man humanity
and cattle honestly it's a dilemma
that's on every character's mind in the
series as early as the first episode we
see the shows here opiate oh sorry I
mean Aaron American voice actors get me
all confused fight with his mother over
which option is the right choice then a
couple minutes later his mother gets
eaten like popcorn shrimp putting that
argument to bed pretty quickly but it
begs the question which option is best
our Erin and the rest of the show's
heroes fools to risk their lives outside
of the walls when they could just lay
back inside the walls and chill
hashtag wall and chill now I already
know what you're thinking why is he
using the American voice dubbing it
sucks
what happened to my mom and I'm so
triggered about that Kitty Tojo SEO is
like the cancer of anime and American
voice dubbing still sucks
okay okay let's all calm down there come
on you're be very on dude don't listen
to these videos so I got to make sure
that the important quotes are in English
and not some alright and regarding the
SAO hate whether you love it or you hate
it there's one thing that we can all
agree on at least it's not skelter
heaven just get along and appreciate
that we all have different nerdy tastes
all right it's just thought I'd ask
all right tongue-in-cheek rebuttals
against hardcore anime fans aside back
to Titan because I'm sure many of you
might be thinking that nobody can relax
inside the walls because the colossal
Titan or armored Titan could just appear
randomly and break the walls down as
they do in the first two episodes except
that's not quite true notice that these
Titans only take down the segments of
wall featuring the gateway in and out of
that part of the city as we learn in
episode 24 the walls themselves are
hardened too strong for the Titans to
tear apart for reasons I'll leave a
mystery due to spoilers suffice it to
say only the entrance is weak enough but
if humanity closed up shop and
completely walled these segments up as
well the colossal Titan could huff and
puff all he wanted but he wouldn't be
able to tear down that wall
mr. Gorbachev he is not but of course
that would also mean that humanity would
be cut off from the outside world so the
question is would that be
such a bad thing could humanity closed
within the walls actually survived well
to properly answer that we need to know
just how large the remaining population
within the walls is and how much land we
have to work with so at the opening of
the series Titans penetrate the wall
Mario killing 10,000 people those that
survived the attack flee into the wall
roses seeking shelter however as we hear
in Episode two 250,000 of those
survivors were sent right back out into
the Titan infested area the narrator
revealed that 250,000 people count as
20% of the surviving population which
means that there are 1 million 250
thousand people living between all 3
walls at the start of the series of the
250,000 people that got sent back out
only about a hundred survived so at the
start of the series the human population
is about nine hundred ninety thousand
one hundred people now to live with
three gigantic walls cut off from the
rest of the world will need enough space
for that population to live lucky for us
there are a number of good looks at
housing throughout attack on Titan
within the city areas sure the houses
are built right next to each other with
narrow roads and alleys in between
they're pretty darn spacious they're a
far cry from your average la hipster
house or a New York studio apartment so
it doesn't seem like they're hurting for
a lot of space to make sure I wasn't
able to take exact measurements but I
did the next best thing
comparison-shopping you see the face
with an attack on Titan closely
resembled a real-world city of Nordling
in Germany a town constructed entirely
inside a meteor crater school right
pulses are built right next to each
other with narrow roads and alleyways
seriously just compare the anime houses
to those IRL it's uncanny how similar
they are so I looked into local
available house listings in that area
and found that the median house there is
about 1500 square feet so assuming that
people are arranged in families of four
some people are sharing homes since
times are hard and that ever-present
couchsurfing rent bumming freeloader
friend that everyone has even when
you're in the middle of the apocalypse
the population of nine hundred ninety
thousand one hundred people we'd need
somewhere around two hundred forty seven
thousand five hundred twenty-five foams
to sustain them all now beach house
covers a baseline 1,500 square feet that
means we need an area of 371 million two
hundred and eighty seven thousand five
hundred square feet at an
absolute minimum to factor in things
like roads streets alleys markets and
businesses I'm gonna quadruple that
number to give us a realistic amount of
space for the city population giving us
the grand total of 1 billion four
hundred and eighty five million one
hundred and fifty thousand square feet
about 34 thousand acres are one hundred
and thirty-eight kilometers squared how
big is that Lots the size of twenty
thousand soccer fields for comparison
Los Angeles is ten times that size at
1,300 square kilometres so about a
million people don't need as much land
as you might think but then again
they're being tightly squeezed into this
area between the walls Wright's raw
we're shown through diagrams as early as
the first episode the actual
measurements of the walled city and when
you do the math it's actually huge from
Walmart all Rosa there's a distance of
100 kilometers between wall Rosa and
wall Sina there's a distance of 130
kilometers and from wall Sina to the
center of it all a distance of 250
kilometers now I'm gonna eliminate this
huge piece of land between wall Mario
and wall Rosa because Titans have taken
it over but given that the walls are
constructed in a circular manner we can
use the formula for the area of a circle
to figure out what sort of space were
working with within the other two walls
in other words it's time to make miss
Alan my ninth grade math teacher proud
this one's for you considering the area
of a circle is PI R squared and the
radius of wall Sina is 250 kilometers
the area within wall Sina alone is a
hundred and ninety six thousand
kilometers squared that's a land area
larger than no joke over half the
countries in the world full countries
padding in wall Rosa's extra 130
kilometer radius you get a grand total
space of 454 thousand square kilometres
for reference this is roughly the
equivalent area of Sweden which by the
way has a population of over nine
million and we only need it for 1
million people based on what we watch in
the show we assume that living between
the walls means making a bunch of
sacrifices but that couldn't be further
from the truth
you literally have a population density
of about two people for every square
kilometer that is
than literally any other place in the
world except for Antarctica
seriously the Titans could be wandering
their stupid little faces off for weeks
without finding a single person to chomp
on and speaking with chomping what about
boom as we see throughout attack on
Titan land isn't the problem it's food
that's constantly running shorts the
most basic meal military volunteers e
consists of a piece of bread a sliver of
meat a bowl of bean soup and of course
potatoes warm delicious potatoes that
need shelter in your stomach and what is
that you're clutching in your right so I
gave it shelter in my stomach sir
Sasha saving the world's view list
Huber's one potato at a time in fact to
promote the opening of an attack on
titan amusement park ride producers sent
press this exact meal and of course
growing food takes extra land so for the
Food and Agricultural Organization quote
the minimum amount of agricultural land
necessary for sustainable food security
is half of a hectare per person who
knows how much a hectare is it converts
to point zero zero five square
kilometers or 1.2 acres per person per
year this means to support the entire
population of nine hundred ninety
thousand one hundred people you'll need
an additional area of 4950 and a half
square kilometers compare that to the
total amount of area within the wall and
we still still have more than enough
space to grow crops for the entire
population and then some but the
challenges keep coming since as we
discover in the second episode a lot of
the space is actually a wasteland unable
to grow crops Oh
this show is trying to get me to force
these kids outside of the walls so hard
unfortunately it's never shown in which
area this wasteland takes up but if you
adhere to the two most prevalent
theories about where this story takes
place it's either in Germany or North
America and based on that information we
can calculate the percentage of farmable
land which in Germany is thirty four
point one percent and in North America
is 11 percent let's take the absolute
worst-case scenario and conclude that
only 10 percent of the available area
within the walls could be used to
cultivate crops and livestock that still
leaves us with about forty five thousand
square kilometers nearly ten times
more than we need for the current
population in fact with that amount of
farmable land you can sustain a
population close to nine million people
go figure it's the population of Sweden
again has anyone actually taken the time
to look into the possibility that this
show actually takes place in Sweden
pewds your Swedish give us the lowdown
attack on Titan remind you of your home
at all giant mr. Goodbody is wandering
around invading your Swiss chalets not a
no long story short there's more than
enough space just within the inner two
walls to both feed and house the
surviving humans even if 90% of the land
is completely useless as farming which
brings us last but certainly not least
to repopulation the old
bow-chicka-bow-wow
fire up some merry white because the
human race has to research somehow I
mean it'll be pretty gross considering
everyone will reek of bean soup
according to census data populations
tend to grow at about 1.1 percent per
year which means if we plug in a basic
exponential growth calculator we can
determine that the population of nine
hundred ninety thousand one hundred
people won't hit nine million for
another two hundred years so even if
only one tenth of the available land was
farmable the walls would still be able
to support its population for another
two hundred years at least
so yeah Eren Mikasa Jaden Armin may be
intent on going out and risking their
lives amongst the Giants fighting the
losing battle of reclaiming their land
one neck nape at a time but they really
should have listened to this guy were
Erin's mom the whole idea is just
irresponsible they have at least 200
years before they even need to consider
the possibility of leaving the walls the
smartest play is to simply seal yourself
in and relax
hashtag wall and chill proof that
sometimes being lazy is mathematically
the correct choice but hey that's just a
theory
Oh film theory and guts know that the
theories done real talk here for a
minute attack on Titan is so so bizarre
and I mean then the best way possible I
mean where else can you have a series
about future humans living in walled off
cities trying to fight against giant
humanoid monster
and that is what I love about anime sure
some of the subject matter can be um
questionable at times but anime tells
some of the most unique off-the-wall
moving exciting and generally
fascinating stories out there it's
unlike any other storytelling medium and
that's why I encourage you to check out
crunchyroll because if you're a hardcore
fan or even just casually curious about
the whole genre like I was to begin with
crunchyroll offers the largest most
diverse collection of anime out there
including of course the episode of the
day attack on titan just in time for
that long-awaited season 2 to come out
oh by the way speaking the follow-ups
remember my full metal alchemist episode
a few months ago well crunchyroll just
got it sister series sister series like
sister location Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood so we can see if the guys
math is better the second time around
and personally out of their new fall
lineup I'm most excited about Cowboy
Bebop I caught a few episodes of it back
in the Toonami days and thought it was a
super interesting series it's this
beautiful noir detective piece but I was
never able to catch up on the whole
series but now finally I can and guess
what you can too
because of this exclusive offer where
you can try out their premium service
crunchyroll premium for 30 days
absolutely free by using the link
crunchyroll.com slash film theorists
that means unlimited anime ad free and
HD across practically any electronic you
can possibly own with new episodes
airing as soon as one hour after they
first air in Japan it's a crazy good
service and some of the proceeds of each
Premium Membership even go back to the
original creators of the anime in the
first place which is just awesome so go
back bend some attack on Titan and Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood and see how
my theories stack up by getting your 30
days of AB free HD anime by going to
crunchyroll.com slash film theorist fi
lm th e o r ist or click the link of the
description it's actually probably a lot
easier than trying to spell out film
theorist yes does a really hard word by
the way anyway click the link the
description attempt typing it into your
url bar and away you'll be glad that you
did
you